we've decided to come outside and try an
experiment out here while the weather is
nice and dry what we've got inside that
huge beaker is water and we've put in an
indicator called phenol failing so at
neutral that's colourless but once we
put this other chemical in there
sodium hydride the sodium hydride will
react with the water and it should be a
very vigorous reaction and it produces
sodium hydroxide which is a base and
that will therefore turn the solution
pink sodium hydride is really quite an
interesting compound I often say that
but I think sodium hydride is
particularly interesting because it
contains the hydride ion which is h- let
me explain here I have a rather crude
model this is a sodium atom and this is
a hydrogen atom and in the sodium atom
there is one electron which is in the
outer shell and in sodium hydride in the
solid one of these electrons is
transferred from the sodium to the
hydrogen so you have sodium plus where
the outer electron has been removed and
over here you have H - that's hydrogen
atom with extra electron
these ions are in the solid and when you
dissolve them in water what happens is
they dissolve so you get na plus and h
minus in solution but the hydrogen does
not hold on to its electron very
strongly and the electron is easily
removed by reaction with water as they
drop the sodium hydride into the water
first of all it hits the surface then it
begins to dissolve and as it begins to
dissolve it forms na plus h minus and
the h minus can then react with water
water as you know is h2o if you take H
minus plus h2o it goes to h2 hydrogen
gas and Oh H minus which is the
hydroxide ion which is what makes things
alkaline so we then have h minus in the
solution the o h minus can then interact
with the phenolphthalein which goes from
colorless to red or pink depending on
the concentration so overall what
happens when you drop it in there is a
great bubbling as the hydrogen gas comes
out and it goes red
sometimes it depends on the particular
reaction conditions the hydrogen can
catch fire and you can get big flames it
looks good but good tenders shouldn't
get big flames
you